things about folding phones right now so
number one sales of these things are up
every single year despite them being
overall a pretty tiny fraction of
overall smartphone sales and number two
it is still very much early adopters and
enthusiasts that are buying these things
maybe with one exception uh but that's
just because they're so expensive and
they also clearly still need some
material science breakthroughs in order
to feel like a regular phone but the
most interesting thing of them all that
i really want to talk about here is how
it so clearly feels like samsung steers
the ship in this particular category so
we got the very first real foldable what
around 2019 not that long ago stuff like
the royal flex pi
it was a hilarious phone but hey it was
technically a folding phone and we could
clearly tell that the idea was pretty
sick so the question became what if
these things start to get really good so
that they no longer feel like a science
fair project but that they get to the
point where it's like just a normal
phone that happens to fold in half
that would be sick so let the r d begin
so now it's three and a half years later
and we have a bunch of different folding
phone options out here now and what i've
noticed is they've basically coalesced
into three
form factors three different distinct
models or versions of this one two three
so it's the fold
the flip
and the
others so the fold this is something
normal that opens up into something big
that's the basic idea and so the
standard among these is samsung's z-flip
4. the competition is getting closer and
there's one notable one that i'll talk
about in a second but basically all of
them are starting to look like this one
i've been using the newest fold 4 on and
off for a few weeks now it looks
basically exactly the same as last year
with slightly more trim bezels it has an
updated chipset new cameras and a more
well hidden internal selfie camera so
the new chipset has done wonders for
this phone performance is consistently
very smooth and the battery while it is
the same physical size as last year is
getting 15 to 25 percent more battery
life because this snapdragon 80 plus gen
1 has just been so rock solid and
efficient while also being more powerful
and then the new cameras while they look
almost exactly the same as last year
from the outside they do offer an
improvement as well nothing
game-changing i mean they're flagship
quality cameras as far as detail and
color and freezing motion which is huge
but that's what it is the rest of the
hardware evolution though has basically
come to a stop like we had a much
smaller cover screen to start now it is
a full corner to corner cover screen
this one this final version here is
three millimeters wider than last year
and the main screen on the inside it
stays at 7.6 inches diagonally but it
changes slightly in aspect ratio from 22
and a half by 18 to 21.6 by 18. it's
still a good looking oled it has a
slightly visible and feelable crease
through the middle and the main
improvement is that it's gotten stronger
and more durable over the years from
being one of the most fragile components
on any phone ever to being able to
actually support a special stylist and
not breaking immediately and that selfie
camera that they hid under this display
in this fourth version
it feels kind of like a gimmick but it
is also now much more impressive
visually like it's much harder to see
during everyday use that there's a
camera back there at all you're just
looking at the content it's almost
invisible but it still takes some of the
worst quality selfies i've ever seen
from a modern day phone not even
exaggeration at all
you know it's functional for video calls
i can get behind its existence but you
should really just be using the back
camera to take selfies on this phone the
absolute best thing about this new fold
4 and i'm not even joking is the new
dock at the bottom it's great it has
massively improved how easy it is to
multitask to the point where i actually
want to do it more while using the phone
it can be a little awkward sometimes
that it sits right above the gesture bar
but you get used to it pretty quickly
and it is endlessly convenient to just
set up a bunch of custom apps ready to
go whenever you want plus some recent
apps on the right maybe the ipad should
experiment with a permanent dock like
this either way this is also coming to
older folds as well but guess what this
still comes in at 17.99 so it's more
expensive than most other phones and
it's still
thicker than most other phones
but there is competition there are
alternatives so the oppo find n which i
did a video on is basically a z fold but
slightly smaller with a more passport
like ratio so that makes the cover
screen feel more like a normal phone a
little bit more reachable but it also
makes the inside screen a bit smaller
there's also the huawei mate x2 which is
the fold but a wedge shape so you can
see they do it a little differently with
the weight distribution which definitely
feels different in the hand it has its
advantages it's also a little bit bigger
which means the outside screen is
extraordinarily tall but the inside
screen
is now up to eight inches diagonally and
the vivo x-fold which i don't have in
front of me but i've seen videos
feels like a fold but with slightly less
of a crease but then there's the new
xiaomi mix fold two and this one has
been extremely impressive to me and it
actually has
possibly real arguments for it over
samsung's standard z-fold 4. this is the
thinnest and prettiest fold in the world
right now yet it somehow packs a larger
4 500 milliamp hour battery inside which
is incredible and it also takes a bit of
a different approach to the hinge where
it's a little more fluid and once you
get past 90 degrees it really wants to
snap open and once you get close it
wants to snap shut there's less stopping
halfway and using it halfway folded like
samsung which hey some people don't
really do anyway so then there's the
flip
the flip being a normal sized phone that
folds down into something smaller this
is actually currently the most popular
version of a foldable phone and once
again pretty much all the flips are
converging on the samsung
z-flip form factor this being the latest
version which is a very iterative update
from the last one there are new cameras
again for the wide and the ultra wide
both 12 megapixels with slightly bigger
pixels on the main camera which helps
images get just a little bit more light
it's moved to a matte finish on the
outside instead of glossy and there are
more quick controls and functionality on
the outside display so you can send
quick pre-written responses to texts and
use more quick settings toggles or call
three of your favorite contacts again
just slightly better it's iterative and
i would guess something that you
probably can or will be able to get
ported back to a flip 3. but the biggest
improvement has absolutely turned out to
be the battery so not only did it move
up to the snapdragon 8 plus gen 1 but
the improvements to the hinge also left
room for a physically larger 3 700
milliamp hour battery this year you can
finally use this form factor all day
without sacrificing battery life and
speaking of the hinge
it's also better than last year i think
this is the best one they've ever made
it's just really firm and confident and
of course doesn't take up as much space
the thing about a small fold like this
is that you have to open the phone to
really use it and depending on what type
of person you are that's either an
upside or a downside like for someone
like me i use my phone all the time you
could call me a power user right i
unlock it all the time this tiny outside
screen is convenient but it's not enough
to do a lot of the stuff i want to do
all the time so i have to take it on my
pocket and then open it up which doesn't
sound like much
but if you own the phone and use it
slowly starts to wear on you but there
are some people who are intentionally
trying to use their phone less
which in this case is actually a huge
win it creates this small barrier
between you
grabbing your phone how many times you
just check your notifications and then
10 seconds later you're just scrolling
through something mindlessly you don't
even know what happened this phone can
kind of prevent that but guess what
there's other flips too and they all
kind of look like this one so you've
heard of the huawei p50 pocket it's a
flip but with a small circular outer
screen instead of a big rectangle you
can still buy the older z-flip it's
still a pretty popular phone from a lot
of carriers in the us even tcl made this
foldable that they never shipped but
that also looks exactly like samsung's
z-flip for a little while the only other
flipper that had any
real character that was unique was the
motorola razer and i i reviewed the
early versions the first one two
generations really leaned into the
nostalgia bit and i liked him they were
cool but now this third version is out
and
not only does it make this hilarious
noise every time you open it
but it it looks and starting to feel
more and more like a z-flip than ever
before i mean it still has some
character but it's a lot less than the
original razers is this because they're
not creative is this because they're
copying just the most popular one or is
it because they're all converging on
maybe the most technically advanced
design or maybe it's a combination of
all this stuff or more i mean clearly
each manufacturer is putting their own
spin on this they have to but yeah
they're all chasing the samsung version
when it comes to foldables and samsung
knows it for the folds
and the flips so then there's
other just the other foldable phone
stuff this is where it gets the most
interesting because there is no samsung
here so i'm considering anything not in
the fold or the flip bucket here and the
most interesting thing about these is
their future is way more questionable so
you have stuff like this which is the
huawei mate xs
really interesting foldable
but it folds from the outside so i did a
whole video on this concept i'll link it
below the like button basically i think
it looks sick
but there's just no way this version can
be as durable as a normal phone until
material science advances significantly
and there's also been some other
concepts tcl has famously shown a
working prototype of like everything
they can think of like they've made
trifolds and rollables and all kinds of
weird stuff never actually sold any of
it but just more proof of concept stuff
that you can do
wild creative things with a pocketable
flexible oled display at the end of the
day though
it's risky to put lots of research and
development money into something that's
not proven yet on the off chance that it
might catch on
but that's why i think we find samsung
like kind of at the forefront of it
steering the ship because that's what
they do remember when they just were
kind of the first ones to make a huge
phone they called it a phablet and they
had like the edge of the screen rolling
off to the side and then suddenly a few
years later every phone was huge like
they've tried so many weird things that
some of them are bound to stick and so
the samsung thing is to just try more
stuff and they make so much money with
the rest of their business that they can
sort of afford to subsidize the r d of
some wild ideas so in the future someday
you know maybe we'll see a foldable
pixel maybe we'll even see a foldable
iphone but for right now in 2022 samsung
steers the ship for the foldables market
until probably the next big material
science update where these things really
start to shrink and improve again and i
would bet money that samsung is the one
currently spending the most money on
finding out what that advancement is let
me know what you think about foldables
in general are you
you